[Music]
[Music]
you patient souls who've been here for a
long time holding your seats welcome I'm
Jane Gould the coordinator of the
technology and culture forum and I'd
like to welcome you to tonight's program
Noam Chomsky on the foundations of world
order 50 years of the UN the World Bank
the IMF and the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights
before we turn to tonight's program I
call your attention to the technology
and culture forums next program
reinventing universities for the 21st
century
there's a sign with all the information
above my head and do come Wednesday
March 3rd at 5:30 p.m. in six one twenty
the technology and culture forum will be
hosting four more programs this spring
if you'd like to be on our mailing list
you can either sign on one of the sheets
of paper on the table in the hall as you
leave or go to our website and just put
yourself on to the list
now to tonight's program
we're all here because we want to hear
Noam Chomsky
Chomsky is honored by MIT as an
institute professor
his doctoral thesis on transformational
analysis began his radical
transformation of the field of
linguistics
honorary degrees learned in professional
societies significant awards his list is
luminous few have escaped his notice
and yet as a public intellectual
professor Chomsky has always taken
seriously his responsibility
to stimulate and lead public debate in
addition to speaking and writing on
linguistics and philosophy
he's taken on intellectual history
contemporary issues International
Affairs u.s. foreign policy to name a
few of his key topics
late this last year I received an email
encouraging me to participate in a 70th
birthday card for Noam Chomsky
online global
hundreds thousands the list went on and
people couldn't resist saying how they'd
been challenged and inspired by Chomsky
tonight he's here to look at the last 50
years what we created what we have and
where we are to go Noam Chomsky
[Applause]
just realized well listening to Jane
announce the title that it's also just
about fifty years since I walked into
this building for the first time but I
won't talk about that
we've
just passed the 50th anniversary of the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
that was a few weeks ago the human
rights regime which was encoded in that
declaration is one of the pillars of the
system of world order that was
constructed on the wreckage of world war
ii
there was there were two other major
foundation stones one was the
international political order which is
articulated in the United Nations
Charter and the third is the
international economic system
sometimes called the Bretton Woods
system designed primarily by the United
States and Britain
right at the end of the war these three
systems were closely integrated
conceptually and in fact the thinking
behind them illustrates that as does the
their interactions over the years and to
a degree that's quite unusual in world
affairs the three foundations
reflected public attitudes and concerns
over quite a wide range
for that very reason the principles that
were
articulated and
some extent instituted those principles
were quite distasteful to elite elements
who were in a namely those who were
actually in a position to construct and
shape and guide the actual world order
and they very quickly took steps to
dismantle or at least attenuate
lofty principles
the conflicts over these matters
constitutes a large part of modern
history post Cold War history that's not
the usual framework of analysis for
discussing it but in my opinion it ought
to be
well large issues there's lot in print
there's many treatises yet to be written
even to be researched I don't think the
topics have been addressed with anything
like enough seriousness but to try to
give I'll try to give some indication of
why I think that's an appropriate and
instructive way to view the
contemporary world system it's it's our
origins I'm the Second World War and
maybe it's likely future so the main
question that I want to get to is
what has been the fate of the three
basic and integrated pillars of world
order that were established half-century
ago and specifically what has been the
role of the United States which has been
the primary actor on the world scene
throughout remains so and the one that's
most important for us for obvious
reasons independently of the
significance and scale of its
contributions which are usually quite
great for equally obvious reasons well
that's the main question that I want to
get to but I'd like to approach it by a
detour
just to make life more complicated and
the detour has two tracks that I'd like
to explore a little bit and then from
them get back to the questions the first
track is
simply to remind everyone of what you
already know we have to bear in mind
that the questions are not abstract and
they're not about some distant planet so
it's not like academic topic for an
academic seminar we're dealing with
questions of life and death of suffering
and pain and despair the voices that are
heard
not that one the voices that are heard
are those of the
are those are the rich and the powerful
naturally there are also those who have
sought to be a voice for the voiceless
their fate hasn't been too happy
some were simply assassinated
by our hands or those working for us a
chapter of modern history that one
doesn't read about too much in fact they
were assassinated and there's quite a
number of them doubly in that they were
first killed and then silenced so you
can do a check and see how many your
friends can tell you the names of
Eastern European dissidents and murdered
their murdered counterparts in Central
America and how many books you've read
by one and by the other and so on it's
an instructive lesson the
but the voices that we hear the ones
that remain are typically the powerful
and that's important because that's not
the only voice that's the voice of a
small minority here and on tiny minority
worldwide well let me illustrate
from right now there are major stories
in the press these last few days on the
g7 meetings the meetings of the seven
richest industrial countries and on the
interchanges between
the their leaders so for example the
president sure acts of France his
interchanges with Robert Rubin who I
guess might be called Co president of
the United States
we have to give Alan Greenspan at least
half the president
the
so that's been all over the the front
pages and those discussions are
interesting and tell you a lot look at
them closely they even not so closely
they review the outcome of these
discussions g7 and the other
interchanges reveal the power of the
United States in a rather dramatic form
and also its extreme isolation even
among the richest countries and if you
will go more closely and you learn a lot
about the true nature of the actually
functioning international economic
system of the difference between the
doctrines that apply to the rich and the
powerful by their insistence and the
opposite doctrines which are imposed on
everyone else that comes out with great
starkness and the articles discussing
the
these these issues come back to that in
connection with the third pillar of
World Order the international economic
system well
there are no stories and I mean none on
the g15 meetings which have taken place
at the same time in Jamaica
last couple of weeks
in the in the national press it's
literally zero I
rely on a database search done by a
friend who has access to that monster
the New York Times The Washington Post
and The Wall Street Journal have no word
on them there's no shortage of
information Associated Press had stories
- they weren't run and the BBC World
Service has had extensive coverage and
if you look around the peripheral press
particularly in Florida there was
coverage Florida I presume them because
of the Latin American connection but the
National Press blanked it out no these
aren't
sunny that these aren't minor countries
these are major these are not what are
dismissed as basket cases like I'm sarin
Africa this is Argentina Brazil Chile
Mexico India Indonesia Nigeria quite
substantial countries in which people
expect to make a lot of money as they
can
17 of them even though it's called g15 a
good part of the world and they do have
something say believe it or not and you
can even read it for example you can
read it on the front page if you happen
to subscribe to the
leading journal and Egypt
the
the which has an English edition so you
can read it in English
the United States what they say at the
g15 meeting is that the United States
and Britain this mostly quotes are
unwilling to enter into a dialogue with
the south the south is what is
euphemistically called the developing
world
which direction they're developing you
can argue about the
US and Britain are unwilling to engage
to enter into a dialogue with the south
which is always forced to make
concessions in the World Trade
Organization to the benefit of the rich
the true story of globalization they
continue is that the North has its g7
has to make maximum benefits and the
south is only entitled to a limited
margin of development and if this margin
is crossed the Western speculators are
there to take you down as quickly as
they can
that's not false but it's a considerable
understatement and the writers surely
know it us power and violence has also
been there to take you down as quickly
as it can if
countries try to pursue the path of
independent development of what's called
in u.s. planning circles
radical nationalism or economic
nationalism or sometimes even excessive
development that's not to be permitted
in the current period of globalization
for reasons I'll get back to you don't
have to send the Marines that often the
speculators can do can do the job
the
g15 meeting goes on to issue a plea to
Western investors it says we don't want
to stifle you but we want to know who
you are and we want you to come and go
in an orderly fashion that's precisely
what the North will not accept the
demand that that not be accepted is a
core part of the multilateral agreement
on investments which has been deflected
thanks to
activist pressure which succeeded in
escaping media controls but deflected
not stopped coming back in other ways
and the point is to prevent what the g15
plea from being realized
the this then is accompanied by grim
account of the effects of the specific
form of globalization that's been
instituted in the past 25 years it has
two major aspects that are relevant here
one is that it's been an economic
failure from from the point of view of
statistics at least not from the point
of view of rich people so economic
growth has slowed over most of the world
and as a fraction of
gross domestic product as a fraction of
economic product the
proportion that goes to working people
has declined so working people are
getting a declining part of a slowing
economy
that's essentially the story
the long term tendency of this is a form
of globalization it's kind of a
globalization of the structural model of
the third world and that's a very clear
structural model you find it just sped
anywhere which is a relic of European I
include here US imperialism
so you find
societies with a
very small sector of extremely extremely
wealthy people usually linked to the
masters a large number of people who are
somewhere between
survival and suffering and a category of
superfluous people in our dependencies
they're often called
disposable people as in Colombia where
you dispose of them send out the death
squads or the paramilitaries I wear a
more civilized society we throw them in
jail instead on various fraudulent
crime words
but that model is spreading it takes a
different form in a rich country like
the United States and a poor country
like say Haiti but the structure is
quite similar and the United States and
Britain it's pretty very explicit and
the rest in the other rich country is
it's partially true and it's
devastatingly true in most of the world
including now Eastern Europe now that
the end of the Cold War has led to it's
more or less predictable outcome and the
countries of Eastern Europe are
returning to what they were before that
attempt at independent nationalism so
the ones that were deep third world
poverty are like Russia or removing
returning to that status the ones that
were part of the West like the Czech
Republic are returning to that status
about us one should have expected in my
opinion that's pretty much what the Cold
War was about but so that's that's
that's that model is a familiar one and
it's now being kind of globalized that's
the globalization process well that's
the g15 view of it you get a much I'm
not sure
more pained and anguished view when you
get to the poorer countries those are
the richer countries outside the
really rich world
well so they are silenced take a second
example a
year ago
the World Trade Organization
celebrated the fiftieth anniversary of
the world the global trading systems
originally cat now the world trade
organization and that one got plenty of
media coverage there was lots of
coverage of the
inspired rhetoric by Bill Clinton and
world leaders talked about the marvels
that had been achieved through global
trade and so on there was also a
spokesperson for the United Nations
there it was the secretary-general of
Punk'd at the UN conference on Trade and
Development the main United Nations
economic research and analysis
organization which is according to its
Charter committed to an international
trading system that promotes economic
and social development and he gave a
talk to representing the rest of the
world the United Nations and he as a
economist at the E closed his speech by
saying no one should be fooled by the
festive atmosphere of these celebrations
outside there is anguish and fear
insecurity about jobs and a life of
quiet desperation
well there was ample media coverage as I
said but it much preferred in fact kept
to the festive atmosphere within
although again you can read this if you
happen to subscribe to a very good third
world journal that's published in Penang
Malaysia
the secretary-general of
is a name for that it's called Free
Press I think the secretary-general of
unk Ted presented the same message same
message pretty much at the recent g15
meeting couple days ago he predicted a
bleak future for the vast majority of
the people of the of the South
although a small sector is and will
continue to be quite wealthy well the
story that he describes is also similar
here including the part about insecurity
and that's not exactly a secret
so Alan Greenspan when he was testifying
before Congress and at Banking Committee
taking pride in the fairy tale economy
as it's known over which he presided a
tribute attributed it in large measure
to what he called greater worker
insecurity meaning workers are just
intimidated and they're frightened
they're not gonna have a job tomorrow
and they're afraid to ask for a raise or
for benefits and so on and that
contributes substantially to what's
called the health of the economy
it's a concept that's uncorrelated with
the health of the people in the economy
but it's a concept it's it's good it
keeps inflation down keeps profits up
does all sorts of good things and it's
real if you look at polls taken say by
Businessweek you find that like round
ninety percent of working people are
have are insecure about their job some
meant very insecure about 70 percent are
afraid that if they try to get involved
in union organizing they all will be
fired the reasons for this these this
intimidation or several some of them
pretty straightforward some of it is
just straight corporate crime which is
very easy when it's backed by a criminal
state the Reagan administration made it
clear was clear and open to the business
world that it was simply not want to
enforce the laws as a result firing of
union organizers went way up
approximately tripled and other measures
could be used to ensure that workers
would stay intimidated that continues
under the Clinton administration
another measure of intimidation is
what are mislabeled free trade
agreements
they're not about free trade and surely
not agreements at least if the
population matters the fact that they're
called agreements is interesting because
it's recognized that at least in any
country that's democratic enough to take
polls like Canada in the United States
that the population is against them but
their agreements nevertheless which
tells you something about the conception
of democracy if they were about
free-trade say cutting back tariffs
enough that could have taken two pages
it's 2,200 pages because it's not about
free trade but what are called free
trade agreements have the property that
they are a way of threatening workers so
the
even some studies on it by one by a very
good labor historian it
Cornell Kate run from Brenner showing
that in about half of organizing efforts
since NAFTA there's been an effort to
disrupt by threat of transfer and it's
not an unreal threat we're organizing is
nevertheless exceeded the number of
transfers is tripled and if you look
where it's triple that's in the mobile
industries like not construction but
manufacture so it's a real threat and it
helps intimidate intimidate people and
it contributes to the health of the
economy and of course in a poorer
country it's a much greater threat
so that's part of the fairytale economy
which is indeed a fairy tale economy for
some people including people in the
sector that most of us come from me in
particular for that sector of the
population it's a fairy tale when you
look at the reports of the fairy tale
economy you find two things mentioned
return on capital and the stock more and
for those who have stock say the rapid
asset inflation of the past years has
made them very rich what it means for
the economy is debated but it certainly
made them very rich so it's a fairy tale
for the 1% of the economy who owned
about half the stock similar figures for
other assets and for the 10% who owned
most of the rest about 85% of the
benefits have gone to about 10 percent
of the population if you go to the next
end percent ii desu isle they've
actually lost net worth during the
clinton recovery go down further looks
uglier over the past years in fact this
recovery is unusual I think
unprecedented in that for the first
first of all it's quite slow by this but
even the standards by the standards in
the post-war period certainly not very
different from the sluggish recoveries
of the 70s and 80 much below the earlier
ones but it's also unusual and that most
of the populations been left out just
now after
this is the peak of the business cycle
it was 1989 so it's almost 10 years just
now
the median is getting back to where it
was in 1989 there's never been such a
slow recovery for the majority it's
probably 70 80 % of the population never
been anything like that before
wages are about real wages are about 15%
below what they were in 1973 in fact
they're back to the level of the
around 1964 or so and a little how you
measure incomes to the extent that they
stay up or staying up because people are
just working a lot more so the typical
American family is putting in about 15
weeks a year more of work than it did 20
years ago to try to keep it a stagnating
or declining
level
if you're interested in data about this
the best general database about this
kind of stuff also written quite clearly
comes out every two years called the
state of work in America Economic Policy
Institute just came out with their
1998-99
edition just a couple of weeks ago which
can fit you in on details up to up to
the current evidence well let me put off
for a moment how this return relates to
the fate of the three pillars but the
point that I'm trying to stress is that
all of this stuff has to do with real
human beings and their fate it's not a
pleasant story and when we bring in the
fate of future generations who don't
have a vote as it's called in the market
and the very restricted market systems
that exist if we bring them in then the
stories even though
well that's the first detour the second
one is and I will get back to the topic
it has to do with the norms and the
conventions for discussing all of this
for discussing World Order and there are
some norms and conventions and if you
depart from them you're kind of not
quite at the discussion the norms and
the conventions are that
the goals the intentions the purposes as
they're sometimes called of the United
States and its leaders are high-minded
sincere benign and other good things and
that crucially is true independently
effect and it is understood to be true
independently effect so for example the
very same books and scholarly articles
and so on that pronounce that as a truth
often also are dedicated to showing that
it's refuted by the facts and that's
called an irony or departure you know
some exogenous factor or something or
other oh that's pretty standard so it's
in indeed the thesis is refuted
overwhelmingly by the doc internal
documentary record the doc record of
planning and even more dramatically by
the historical record of practice but it
doesn't matter the principle remains
true and it provides the framework of
discussion and one part of a good
education is to understand that to get
that
internalized enough so you can then take
part in the debate which proceeds in
this fashion there are it's reminiscent
of
medieval and early modern
theological dogma and it's interestingly
it's sometimes even presented in those
terms especially in what's called
realist international theory
however although the comparison comes to
mind I think it's unfair it's kind of an
insult to medieval theology oh I mean
that quite seriously and I'll explain
why if you're interested but let me put
it aside anyway it has something of the
flavor of a theological principle notice
that these principles don't apply to
anyone else so for example nobody pays
anything to the high-minded rhetoric of
Stalin's Constitution or the exalted
rhetoric that accompanies what those who
carry it out call humanitarian
interventions which the most obvious
cases in this century I suppose at least
to be judged by the rhetoric are
Mussolini's invasion of Ethiopia the
Japanese invasion of Manchuria and North
China and Hitler's invasion of
Czechoslovakia the rhetoric was very
impressive and full of
humanitarian ideals and noble purposes
and so on I'm like most propaganda
wasn't totally false like fine fragments
of truth in it the
so for example Hitler was invited in by
the President of Slovakia and the
Japanese actually had one of the leading
Chinese nationalists as a puppet and so
on
but we don't pay any attention to that
stuff we don't regard that as evidence
that of benign intentions in those in
other cases the principles hold only at
home not anywhere else and here they
hold irrespective of the facts and in
the very often in the very same
documents Ayse got all the articles
which present the facts to refute them
it's kind of misleading to give examples
because that would understate the
uniformity and the extremism and it
would be misleading the quote the press
so I won't because that's too easy
let me just give one example which
happens to be the last one that I looked
at last night in a current Journal of
International Affairs it's kind of an
interesting case is a very good scholar
highly critical of US government
policies which makes it more interesting
this article - it's worth examining not
only because it illustrates the
conventions but because of what we
discover about
what we discover when we look a little
more closely
not only about contemporary history but
also about ourselves what we do how we
deal with that the record is
particularly instructive in this case
because the Cold War is almost totally
irrelevant
this goes back a long way and never has
been any cold war irrelevant the
institution has been recognized the
institutions of power and decision
making remain unchanged from that we
conclude if we're rational that it's
likely to be a pretty good predictor of
where things are going to go at least if
we allow them to go that way
these
well these in fact
the the articles by a well-known milli
scholar there's also a leading policy
analyst at the Council on Foreign
Relations and elsewhere he's been highly
critical of US policy toward the Middle
East which is his specialty the article
is to and he gives a recommendation
which in fact is highlighted by the
journal so it's like the most important
part of the recommendation it says the
United States should more energetically
promote central u.s. foreign policy
themes especially freedom democracy and
human rights
notice these are central u.s. foreign
policy themes no argument or evidence is
presented to establish that fact because
none is needed that is a theological
dogma it's like God is great or
something you don't have to present
evidence for that it's just a truth then
the article proceeds after having
established the truth and it goes on and
this is quite typical to describe how
the United States has consistently acted
contrary to its central aren't foreign
policy themes in the Middle East
he then the author then goes on to say
I'm quoting now there is no doubt not
only is true but there is no doubt that
American foreign policy does adopt a
separate standard for the Middle East
when it comes to such values as
democracy and human rights well to show
that there's a double standard you do
need evidence so he presents some
evidence the evidence is that as he
shows the United States does not uphold
such values in the Middle East which is
the area of his expertise and attention
but it does uphold them elsewhere
strikingly he points out four major
Muslim states the most in the Middle
East so that makes the point very clear
and the most important case of course as
he notes is Indonesia largest Muslim
state which he cites to establish the
certainty of the judgement that the
United States has a separate standard
for the Middle East well breaking with
the convention let's look at the dogma
keeping to the single and most important
examples cited namely Indonesia where
the United States upholds its values of
democracy and human rights well very
much like Hitler Mussolini and Japan
this doctrine isn't totally false so on
May 20th
1998 all right so that's last May the
United States did make its first
statement in favor of democracy in
Indonesia Secretary of State Albright on
last May 20th called upon President
Suharto to resign and provide for a
democratic transition a few hours later
he resigned maybe coincidence maybe it
tells you something about power
relations you can figure that out for
yourself
so last May we called for democracy from
the time that the Suharto took power in
October 1965 until May 1998 this
gentleman was our kind of guy as the
Clinton administration called him while
he was massacring and torturing and
robbing
in a quite impressive fashion kind of
one of the world records of the modern
period the Clinton administration even
went so far as to suspend its
congressionally mandated review of
Indonesia's appalling labor practices
while at the same time praising
Indonesia for bringing them into closer
conformity with international standards
and the Clinton administration also
avoided congressional restrictions on
military support for our and a guy found
various ways to pay for it out of other
pockets and that sort of thing but it is
true that last May the United States
underwent religious conversion and for
the first time called for democracy in
Indonesia the force of the comparison
with the Middle East however somewhat
weakened by the fact that the same
conversion occurred there pretty much
the same time in December 1998 Secretary
of State Albright announced and quoting
we have come to the determination that
the Iraqi people would benefit if they
had a government that really represented
them so in both the middle-east and
Indonesia contrary to the theses of the
United States underwent a religious
conversion in favor of the central
themes of its foreign policy at least on
paper you can evaluate the accuracy
about at the same time last last year in
the case of Iraq before that the US
policy was to support what was called an
iron fist the iron fist was Saddam
Hussein for a long time he was our kind
of guy right through his most murderous
crimes and most monstrous crimes after
he committed his first true offense the
thesis shifted we still wanted an iron
fist but it had to be a clone someone
who would rule with an iron fist just as
Saddam Hussein had done during the
period when he was our kind of guy that
was pretty much official policy but on
paper at least it's now changed because
as of last December we discovered that
they would benefit from a government
that represented them so in 1998 then
the United States did announce support
for democracy but both in the Middle
East and Indonesia well what does this
tell us about the central themes of u.s.
foreign policy answer tells us nothing
whatsoever because these are doctrinal
truths and therefore facts are simply
irrelevant like you know god is great
and merciful you know look at factual
truth
if you look more put it aside
let's look don't take too many detours
let's look a little more closely at
Indonesia where there is no doubt that
these themes of democracy and human
rights were put into practice there's a
lot of concern right now about the
possibility that Indonesia may break up
in two separate you know kind of either
Federation or maybe separate territories
and that prospect is very much deplored
however the objection to it whatever it
may be is certainly not an objection of
principle and we can find that out quite
easily if we bother to look at the
irrelevant facts so in 1958 that
happened to be official US policy secret
but we now know it was official US
policy to break up Indonesia the and the
United States in fact sponsored carried
out a major insurgent counterinsurgency
well insurgency operation subversive
operation probably the major one of the
post Second World War period
to try to break up Indonesia supported a
rebellion in the outer islands those the
islands where the oil is and where most
US investments were and the that was the
goal to separate them off and the
purpose was the reason was that the
national government was neutralist and
independent and in fact was far too
democratic which was extremely worrisome
to Washington the government was not
suggesting it was a model democracy but
it was allowing parties of the pores to
function there was a major party which
represented were peasants and it was
allowed to function I was doing better
and better in each election and that was
appalling news in Washington if we look
at the internal record we discover that
most of which has been suppressed
incidentally but bits and pieces of
leaked and there's some good scholarly
studies of it one in fact by the leading
founder of US Southeast Asian Studies
George canna Cornell he the
some documents that have come out in the
official channels the fear was that the
government was they say far too
democratic and it would be impossible as
they say as they put it to suppress the
parties of the of the left by ordinary
democratic means and therefore they
would have to be the word is eliminated
that's the Joint Chiefs
the meanwhile the outer islands would be
separated off so inside what's left bad
guys have to be eliminated
the outer islands will be separated the
u.s. will take them over well the
rebellion failed
but not before destroying
whatever fabric of parliamentary
democracy existed in Indonesia and now
after 40 years we're calling for it to
be restored
the
after the failure of the rebellion the
United States turned to what is standard
operating procedure when you want to
overthrow a civilian government support
the
try to undermine the civilian government
but support the military because they're
the ones you're gonna overthrow the
government for you that's absolutely
standard case after case
you know [ __ ] is one example the the
real story about what lies behind the
iran-contra is the same and we know it
had nothing to do with hostages because
it was started when there were no
hostages but that's and it's just
standard operating procedures in
Indonesia it worked the u.s. tried down
there - civilian government supported
the military
worked by 1965 there was indeed a
military coup so hard to took over an
army inspired massacre then took place
the CIA described it as one of the worst
massacres of the 20th century comparable
to Hitler Stalin and now it was fairly
accurately reported in the United States
it was a staggering bloodbath New York
Times called it a
boiling blood staggering mass slaughter
that was The Times phrased
Time magazine devoted a whole section to
to what they call the boiling blood bath
and which hundreds of thousands of
people were massacred mostly for
peasants and the leadership of the
peasant of the poor peasant party was
indeed eliminated it was reported
accurately and with complete euphoria
there was such joy over it that it
couldn't even be suppressed it's kind of
been written out of history but go back
and read the journals of the time the
euphoria is total across the
intellectual spectrum freedom house was
applauding and so on all right the the
US government applauded
Secretary of Defense McNamara testified
before Congress that the military aid
that we had given to the millet to the
Indonesian military had paid dividends
in private letter to President Johnson
he was particularly proud of the
training that Indonesian military
officers received that American
universities were they've gotten the
right ideas about how to carry out mass
slaughter comparable to Hitler Stalin
and Mao the country became paradise for
investors Suharto became the darling of
the United States our kind of guy
remained so when he invaded East Timor
like that maybe third or a quarter of
the population and that continues right
into 1997 then something went wrong he
apparently committed a crime what crime
is it well in fact the crime if you look
closely which led to the religious
conversion in favor of a democratic
transition here there were actually two
crimes two standard ones one crime is he
started dragging his feet about IMF
workers the IMF rules were imposing
extremely serious
hardships on the people of Indonesia and
so hard it was kind of slow about
following orders crime number one the
second crime is he just lost control
there was a democratic uprising and
the army wasn't backing him anymore and
at that point he's useless so therefore
he got the advice to permit a democratic
transition in which he handed power over
to his hand-picked vice president well
that's the moment at which the United
States after 40 years
began to at least on paper to implement
its
central theme of its policy in the area
where there is no doubt that it has
always implemented it remember as
distinct from the Middle East by
committing those two crimes so hard to
have followed a very classic path
another recent example is Mobutu Saddam
Hussein do that yay Marcos Somoza
Trujillo it's kind of a long list same
two crimes or the ones that mattered you
stopped following orders you lose
control you're out and we're in favor of
a democratic transition this happens
routinely
regularly but it doesn't teach anything
you don't learn anything about policy
from that because the nature of policy
is a theological dogma and therefore no
evidence tells you anything well let's
look a little more closely at 1958 I
still promise to get back to the theme
if you're willing to hold down it's very
revealing
in 1958 the National Security Council
main planning body had been secret
meetings now publicized in which john
foster dulles secretary of state
presented
described the crises on the world scene
so there's three major crises in the
world seen in 1958 one was Indonesia the
second was Algeria the third was the
Middle East
notice that they're all Muslim countries
but there was no clash of civilisations
at that point those of you who are
respectable intellectuals will know that
now we have to soberly debate the
classroom civilizations because the Cold
War pretext for vention has collapsed
and we need what's called a new paradigm
but then we still had that pretext so we
didn't need a new paradigm so the three
major crises were Indonesia Algeria and
the Middle East more in fact they were
Muslims irrelevant but something isn't
irrelevant namely they all had oil in
fact there were oil centers and in fact
the effort to
cut off the outer islands was related to
the concern u.s. concerns over Middle
East oil there were some concerns that
it was getting out of control and they
needed some temporary supplements
temporary because Indonesia is nor near
the scale of the Middle East but
significant well you look back at what
happened and bear in mind that the
United States is a global power so its
policies are usually carried out
consistently in many different places
and a lot of other things were happening
in 1958 the subversion in Indonesia the
rebellion Indonesia was the largest of
the clandestine operations maybe the
largest ever but there were others in
Burma of the United States was moving to
overthrow the regime supporting a
Chinese nationalist army that had
partially taken refuge there and that
the United States was supporting there I
won't go into the details but that led
Burma at that time had an elected
government that led to a military coup
the installation of the current military
regime in Burma one of those myrtl in
the world it also was instrumental in
making Burma the leading heroin producer
in the world of position it now holds
and a real horror story the state of
Massachusetts now has a kind of boycott
we can trace that right back to 1958
right parallel to the when we were
carrying out the central themes of our
foreign policy in Indonesia
another case right next door was
Cambodia
also at a neutralist government which
the United States didn't like the US was
supporting an attack on it that attack
didn't work in 1958 but it did work in
1970 the same forces overthrowing
princey anok's government that led to
the huge u.s. bombing the Khmer Rouge
everything that followed did not talk
about that a third a third place where
something was going on in 1958 was again
right nearby and Laos Laos had its first
and last free election in 1958 came out
the wrong way parties the left one US
wouldn't accept that military coup took
place the u.s. installed what was called
a pro-western neutralist and he wasn't
good enough so ultra-right general was
put in that led to a total disaster it's
sort of paved the way and that came very
close to a World War I the it ended up
with us carrying out the heaviest
bombing in history against a defenseless
peasant Society in northern Laos and the
effects of that are still with us though
you wouldn't read it you can even read
it in the US newspaper there's a very
good article on it in a Wall Street
Journal by their veteran Asia
correspondent
about a year and a half ago
unfortunately it's the Asian edition of
The Wall Street Journal they didn't have
it in the US edition but it's quite a
good article he gives an estimate of
there's honey unknown numbers of
unexploded bomblets just littering the
Plain of Jars hundreds of millions of
them were dropped they're much worse
than landmines these are not aimed at
property they do nothing against a truck
they're aimed to kill people they're
their murder weapons they're little
think colorful things that you know kid
can pick up a farmer can hit or
something they had an failure to explode
rate of about twenty to thirty percent
according to their manufacturers
Honeywell and you know crummiest
technology maybe it's hard to believe
that that wasn't built in but maybe the
technologists among you can assess that
likelihood anyway they're supposed to
have a twenty to thirty percent failure
to explode rate which means they're
around all the time as any personnel
weapons and they're still they're huge
numbers of them there is a the estimated
according to The Wall Street Journal
report the casualties may range up to
thousand a year of which more than half
our deaths other numbers or less but
some since nobody's counting you know
nobody really knows but numbers of that
kind are considered not unreasonable by
the Wall Street Journal in its Asia
edition the
there is a mine clearing group
british-based mine advisory group
civilian but you know based ultimately
in the British Army and other countries
have come in as the British press
reports the United States is conspicuous
by its absence in the mine clearing
operation and furthermore the right-wing
British press is bitterly complaining
over the fact that the United States the
Pentagon refuses to provide
what are called render harmless
procedures
procedures that would defuse the mine so
they wouldn't kill the people who are
trying to clear them that's a military
secret and in fact the whole thing is a
secret in the United States have to work
pretty hard to find out anything about
it that's a fact so that's Laos
another case in 1958 was Vietnam I won't
even talk about that in each case
including all of these including
Indonesia the US interventions which
were significant were led to hideous
atrocities and in fact destroyed the
basis of democracy and in fact were to a
large extent driven by that purpose as
in several of the cases I've mentioned
however that doesn't influence the dogma
it's still correct it is still there
still no doubt that in the Middle East
only the United States doesn't live up
to its high ideals but does in these
places well take a little more closer
look at 1958 I won't go into this and
bring it up later if you like but the
other major case was in fact Iraq
Iraq was pulling out how to nationalists
revolution it was Politico to the u.s.
anglo-american condominium over oil that
was going on right in 1958 and was a
major phenomenon look at the documentary
record then you get a pretty good
explanation of everything that's going
out until today okay let me drop that
one of the things that's going on today
which is quite striking and leads me to
the topic finally is a kind of a minor
aspect of the bombing last December the
US UK bombing one interesting aspect of
it what was that it is in
blatant and flat violation of the UN
Charter and international law
international law that's one of the
three pillars the world order the
basic principle the UN Charter is that
the threat or use of force in
international affairs is banned except
under highly restricted circumstances
which don't apply or if specifically
authorized by the Security Council
otherwise banned threat or use of force
there's no serious doubt that the US and
UK just flatly ignored that they didn't
try to get you a Security Council
authorization for the simple reason they
knew they'd never get it so therefore
they just bombed now in the United
States there is essentially no
discussion of this I've done a fairly
extensive review and where it's
discussed as it occasionally is it's
considered a kind of a technicality the
reason being if a reason is ever given
that we cannot allow others to veto our
policy decisions as required by the UN
Charter and international law but we
alone cannot others must stand by that
but we can all right that is
unchallenged as far as I can discover
try to find some interesting exercise
try to find some challenge to that
doctrine I haven't found it there is
some in England there's a lot elsewhere
so for example the Indian in India the
Association of jurists has a case before
the World Court condemning the US and
Britain for war crimes you won't read
about that either but here it's not
discussed because it's taken for granted
that that's correct we cannot submit
ourselves to international law or the UN
Charter because we are a violent lawless
criminal rogue state and that is right
and just that's what it means and there
is near Universal endorsement of that
principle among educated sectors at
least which should be taken as a warning
by the world and indeed is taken as a
warning by the world which doesn't like
it but can't do much about it we're the
ones who can do something about it
the official stand we seem displeased
judging articulate sectors educated
sectors support it so I don't really do
anything about it
the official stand during the bombing in
December was quoted that we prefer to
act through our allies but will resort
to force alone if we have to notice that
we don't even prefer to act through the
United Nations as required by
international law on the Charter we made
the first join our allies if they're
willing to but UN is out in fact the
timing of the bombing was presumably
intended as a slap in the face to the
Security Council the bombing was timed
just as the Security Council was being
called to an emergency session to deal
with the question of Iraq and it hadn't
been notified and if that didn't make
headlines here people understood it
elsewhere I think like that don't happen
by accident and they were understood
well that's accepted across the spectrum
and it's accepted in other cases too so
take a look at the rumbly a meetings in
Kosovo there was a debate there about
just what to do the debate was between
the United States and its allies and the
NATO powers nobody else around and the
debate was over the wording the should
the wording of the NATO decision to bomb
be stated as being authorized by the
United Nations or only being endorsed by
the United Nations the u.s. insisted on
endorsed as the New York Times put it it
wanted to avoid the neuralgic word
authorised which would entail that the
that international law has some
significance and the US won't accept
that even at the rhetorical level and as
usual the u.s. won
so the most they get to do is authorize
is endorsed not authorized the little um
order which is what these cute law
requires and it's not just in this case
it's in every case so take say the
bombing the Sudan last August I'm it's
now conceded no nobody can't rise to
very few even try to deny that the US
just bombed the pharmaceutical plant in
Sudan and destroyed half of Sudan's
pharmaceutical industry well you know
sometimes things go wrong there's no
talk about war crimes no talk about
reparations not even any talk about an
apology I mean why should we apologize
if we destroy half of the
pharmaceuticals in a poor East African
country be serious furthermore that's
accepted across the spectrum okay
there's a further history for this ten
years ago the United States took the
same stand explicitly with regard to the
World Court
dared to
carry out a follow a case against the
United States and indeed to condemn the
United States for the unlawful use of
force and its war against Nicaragua
the United States position was clear and
explicit the State Department legal
department said that we cannot accept
world court jurisdiction they explained
why the reason is that other states do
not agree with us they do not accept
their policies that's and they said we
must therefore reserve to ourselves the
right to decide when court rulings apply
and we must reject
court rulings I'm quoting now for any
dispute involving matters essentially
within the domestic jurisdiction of the
United States as determined by the
United States the example in question
was the US war against Nicaragua and the
United States determined that that was
within its domestic jurisdiction so the
World Court could get lost and that was
done with virtually a hundred percent
support of educated intellectuals
including leading advocates of world or
write articles and law journals and so
on and so forth
the New York Times dismissed the court
as a hostile forum and so it went other
court judgment was never even reported
and it was radically violated okay
that's the world court this goes back
much further back in 1962 Dean Acheson
highly respected statement statesman you
know advised senior advisor the Kennedy
administration
informed the American Society for
international law that a situation in
which our country's power position and
prestige are involved cannot be treated
as a legal issue
he was referring to the US embargo
against Cuba which of course he
recognized was illegal but nothing in
which our power position and prestige
are involved can be treated as a legal
issue and accordingly at that time you
heard Adlai Stevenson at the United
Nations defending the u.s. attack
against South Vietnam as defense against
internal aggression the Vietnamese South
Vietnamese were carrying out internal
aggression in South Vietnam and we were
defending South Vietnam against them we
were defending South Vietnam against
what John F Kennedy called the assault
from within that's when he launched the
assault from without this goes way back
in earlier years that had been in secret
so in earlier years the flight rejection
of the Charter is explicit very explicit
but in secret goes back to 1947 first
memorandum of the National Security
Council in which it called for national
mobilization in the United States
support for military action paramilitary
action other such things in Italy if the
Communists took power by legal means in
an election in other words if a
democratic election came out the wrong
way we would use force to overthrow it
that's
1947 NSC one story goes on from there
the innovation in the Reagan years was
that the contempt for international law
became completely overt wasn't even
secret anymore under - lost any pretense
so the conclusion is the only reasonable
conclusion is that the first pillar of
world order the International political
order has totally disappeared it's
available as a weapon against enemies
but nothing else remains except the
theological dogma that we uphold world
order international law that remains
independently the facts so nothing else
remains well let's proceed
turn to the universal declaration second
pillar of world order this is a tightly
integrated document
the
the it has conventionally divided in
three parts civil and political rights
socio-economic rights and we're called
solidarity rights the integration of all
of those was stressed from the beginning
you look at the background it's clear
repeatedly been stressed since times
short so I won't run into run through
the history the major Law Review article
that just appeared on the 50th
anniversary by Harvard Law Professor
Mary and Glendon stresses that the
universal declaration elevates socio
social economic and cultural rights to
fundamental rights status and that that
is a crucial part of the
universalization of rights carried out
in the Universal Declaration in short
there is no place for any sort of
relativist demand that certain rights
must be
relegated to secondary status in accord
with say Asian values or some other
pretext
Glendon also points out quite accurately
the support for that was very
broad-based at the time have to remember
the time this is right at the end of the
Second World War there were
values of that kind that kind of
expressed in the UD were deeply
entrenched in the anti-fascist popular
forces in Europe and in the colonial
world and even in the United States that
was deeply disturbing to us a leets who
intended to create a very different kind
of world order and indeed were quite
explicit about it but the dog
remains and it proclaims a more
self-congratulatory version well there
were some who did dismiss the Universal
Declaration
as meaningless so there's an often
quoted phrase of Andre wyszynski 'he's
the Russian delegate whose record
doesn't have to be paint us he dismissed
the Universal Declaration as a
collection of pious phrases
and it was dismissed as quoting a letter
to Santa Claus by Jean Kirkpatrick
Reagan's UN Ambassador who was deriding
the socio-economic
provisions of the Universal Declaration
moving on a couple of years it is an
empty vessel a dangerous incitement
preposterous
that's Morris Abram UN ambassador to the
UN Commission on Human Rights
he's
explaining Washington's rejection of
what was called the right to development
which if you look at it's a very close
paraphrase of the
socio-economic provisions of the
Universal Declaration that was vetoed by
the United States alone essentially
vetoing the
socio-economic provisions of the UD the
u.s. also radically violates the civil
and political provisions I won't go
through the details but quite clear and
not surprising one of the latest major
Amnesty International reports is about
this in brief two pillars of World Order
have been effectively demolished
except as ideological weapons that
doesn't mean that the people of the
world shouldn't defend them they do
remain ideals that people should try to
defend they should fight for and that
they should also transcend because
they're not the end of the road by any
means but to take that stand in the
United States you have to first carry
out an act of intellectual liberation
you have to free yourselves from the
doctrines of the faith you don't do that
you can't even enter into the into the
fray first I have to free yourselves
from the doctrines of the faith and at
least be willing to subject them to him
verification if they're not even subject
to empirical verification there's no
point discussing these matters clearly
if they are you can ask whether this
analysis is correct there's some
different analysis is correct well
that's a radical that just the
willingness to subject them to
examination the doctrines that's a
radical departure from prevailing norms
including everything in the educational
system and academic scholarship in the
media and everywhere else so it's not
small well a couple of words about the
third pillar the Bretton Woods system
one of its central which again was
totally tightly integrated with the
others and that's worth understanding a
central component of the Bretton Woods
system was regulation of Finance
and there were several purposes for the
reasons for this one reason was that it
was an effort that was understood that
the regulation of finance would harm the
global economy they're good reasons for
that and they've been illustrated in
recent years the trouble is that
financial markets as was understood are
quite volatile and unpredictable at the
quote a couple of MIT economists
specialists on this financial markets
are governed by panics manias and
crashes by they swing far above and
below any kind of sensible fundamental
values creating bubbles that will burst
Paul Samuelson who says the evidence for
that is overwhelming and this was
understood back in the 40s no so you
deregulate financial markets gonna have
a disaster and it will harm the general
economy that was one reason a second
reason was closely related to world
order in human rights one reason for
both capital controls and keeping
currencies within a narrow band was that
it's that it was understood that the
regulation of capital is a tremendous
weapon against democracy and social and
socio-economic rights before mentioning
that let me just say that the current
debate between the United States and its
g7 partners is over keeping currencies
within a narrow band if you read the
articles on this you notice that the US
the g7 position Germany Japan and France
and so on is maybe not written but the
other g7 countries is that
currently major currencies should be
kept sort of closely interconnected
and that was rejected as crazy by US
Secretary of the Treasury Robert Rubin
because if we were to agree to that it
would mean that some other authority
might determine that we're not allowed
to lower interest rates to stimulate the
economy if we want to so if the economy
sinking into recession we won't be able
to allow interest rates because that'll
affect currency values and it would be
crazy to allow other country to any
other country to allow us to any
international organization to prevent us
from carrying out those fiscal policies
exactly the fiscal policies that we
force on every other country as the very
same articles point out without any
sense of contradiction
take a look think about it
why is deregulation of Finance a weapon
against democracy and human rights well
very obviously and it was understood the
reason is that
if capital flow is unregulated it will
it can it will quickly create what some
international economists call a virtual
Senate a Senate consisting of
concentrated international financial
capital which will simply impose
decisions on government but by the
threat of capital flight so if some
government pursues irrational policies
so policies that are aimed at helping
the population let's say instead of
raising profits for investors and are
therefore irrational like education or
health or environmental policies or
whatever it may be you can force them to
stop simply by pulling all the capital
out of the country which sends the
country of course this interest rates up
since the country the depression the
usual consequences so therefore unless
capital is controlled you've got you
very sharply restricted
democracy and human rights well--that's
was understood then and it is understood
now the Bretton Woods system with
financial regulation persisted through
roughly in 1970 that's a period that's
commonly called the Golden Age of
post-war capitalism period of high
growth high growth of productivity
expansion of the social contract
so-called welfare state which turned the
Universal Declaration into something a
little more than a letter to Santa Claus
from the early 1970s that system was
dismantled
first at the initiative the United
States Britain came along later others
other major economies not until the
eighties and the results wouldn't have
surprised the founders of the Bretton
Woods system the results have
transferred
some economists call it a transfer from
a golden age to a Litton age in the
period since there has been slowdown of
the economy globally and the social
contract has been dissolved dramatically
in the US and Britain some extent
elsewhere inequalities going way up
consequences I have party described
briefly one region of the world
temporarily escaped from this that's
East Asia which is quite different from
Southeast Asia there there was quote the
chief economist of the World Bank there
was an unprecedented economic miracle
which was based on the fact that they
disregarded the religion as he calls it
the religion that markets know best and
they disregarded the prescriptions of
the international financial institutions
so-called Washington Consensus and they
carried out an unprecedented economic
miracle in the early 1990s South Korea
liberalized capital flow under very
heavy US pressure I should say one of
several factors that's a large factor in
the subsequent collapse that's generally
agreed
nine up till
1997 or 1998
the global economic system was
considered
really great it was in fact what's
called an economic miracle fairytale I'm
very much the way Mexico was an economic
miracle during the period when the
number of billionaires was rising about
as fast as the poverty level that's
there was no crisis until
1997-98 all there was was anguish and
fear insecurity about jobs and a life of
quiet desperation ahead of debt that's
not a crisis that's I think that's a
miracle it because that was only outside
the doors remember inside the festive
atmosphere was
exuberant so but by 1998 the festive
atmosphere inside was a little becoming
a little disturbed the interests of rich
people were being affected so we moved
from economic miracle to crisis those
are technical terms again don't have
much to do with what's happening to the
people has to do a lot with what's
happening to rich people rich powerful
people and their interests were starting
to be disturbed so all of a sudden we
had a crisis as distinct from anguish
and fear and so on well that crisis is
now all over the paper
front pages wasting time on it so it's
interesting one side effect of the
crisis is that all of these certainties
have dissolved so the Bank for
International Settlements in Basel which
is you know the most conservative and
respectable institution that exists it's
called the central bank of central
bankers and their latest report last
summer they said nobody knows nobody has
a clue as to what's going on and they
urged that we have humility instead of
issuing
confident pronouncements let's at least
have enough humility to admit that we
haven't got a clue as to what is
happening or what to do about it leading
economists from around here Cambridge
have been recently publishing articles
in which they say that the international
economy is dimly understood
that we may be heading into third-world
style xxx style depression and we don't
what to do about it actually the real
crisis is much more fundamental and I'll
finish by just giving two quotes but I
think capture it rather will
one of them both reason one is from an
event that was organized by Jesse
Jackson / Martin Luther King weekend in
January this was an event in Manhattan
to support Bill Clinton in the moment of
his terrible trials there were lots of
celebrities who came and sort of admired
one another and so on among them was the
president of the New York Stock Exchange
I'm quoting from the press now he told
New York Times he told mr. Clinton that
dr. King is surely smiling down on the
gathering recognizing how Clinton had
benefited my little corner of southern
Manhattan
which is quite accurate other little
corners of southern Manhattan fared
rather differently but the stock
exchange on that
mr. Clinton doubtless showered many
benefits so no doubt Martin Luther King
is smiling down on
that's a an appropriate comment
reflecting the realities of a political
system in which in the last election
November 1998
95 percent data have just come in
recently ninety-five percent of winning
candidates outspent their opponents
meaning you could predict up to 95
percent accuracy who's gonna win just
looking at how much money they had so
it's not like Russia where he could
brick a hundred percent that it was
going to be the Communist Party it's
only 95 percent furthermore if you look
at the
contributions same data business
contributions outspent labor
contributions by that twelve to one
which is highly misleading remember
because labor represents way more people
and individual contributions that
measure undoubtedly or skewed at least
as much so what that translates into to
put it into English is that a small that
a little corner of southern Manhattan
and a couple of other little corners
like it essentially purchase candidates
and put them in office and then set
conditions that they're going to have to
meet or else and also set the general
framework for policy just by virtue of
their power
becoming the virtual Senate as I
mentioned once these instruments are in
their hands the second quote of course
they also require a powerful state
they're very insistent on that there has
to be a powerful state which will
socialize risks and costs and will make
sure that there's no unpleasant noises
and servants quarters so that still got
to be there but not with its own
functions second quote last one is from
David Rockefeller reflecting on the
current scene recall that David
Rockefeller is at the liberal end of the
spectrum he's what's called the part of
the establishment left it's called
without irony I should say he's
commenting on the reduction of the role
of government in public affairs
something that business has always
favored he says
side comment the role of government
means the role of the population right
of all institutions that are around with
all its flaws whatever they may be
government is the only one in which at
least in principle there's some
possibility of participation often in
practice too in the operations of
General Electric there are no
possibilities in principle so government
is the one institution of the general
institutional framework in which people
may have a role sometimes do and that
role is declining
businesses happy about that but he says
well that reduction of democratic
participation is of course welcome
there's another side to that
somebody has to take government's place
and business seems to be the logical
entity to do it okay that's Rockefeller
it's there he goes on say it's the
responsibility of business to fill this
gap made by the disappearance of
democratic government it's certainly not
the
role of the public that's for sure
that's the establishment left when you
move over to the right the message gets
a lot harsher well that's a pretty fair
picture of the current drift of policy
sure you know corporations gain the
right of persons through judicial
activism early in this century they're
not ordinary persons like you and me
they're are immortal persons they have
extraordinary power unlike
flesh-and-blood persons they also demand
the rights of states and they get them
under NAFTA they've partially gained
them under the amai they gain them still
more fully in fact they would gain
additional rights which are described as
if they're innocuous but they surely
aren't if you think about them under ma
eye these persons
fictitious legal persons are demanding
what they call national treatment that's
a right that no flesh-and-blood person
can claim so under national treatment
general electric can function freely in
Mexico but suppose that some
flesh-and-blood Mexican tries to get
national treatment in New York no that's
not gonna work so this is only for
fictitious collectivist legal entities
those kind of persons get the rights of
states the rights of national treatment
all right and furthermore they have a
right and a responsibility to take over
the functions of government they must do
that that would therefore reduce
democratic form still further
internally they're basically tearing
those I mean I think that's in question
and they try to run the global society
including the sort of minimal market
system in an integrated fashion they do
rely on the powerful states to make sure
that they can get what they want they
also demand and in large part gain the
right to shape opinions and attitudes
and beliefs that's the role of the
corporate media and in fact the
educational system to a large extent
that is if the right to define what a
human being is what constitutes a human
life and do so well quite apart from the
continuing assault against the
proclaimed values of democracy and human
rights and freedom and all good things
these tendencies if they are tolerated
could lead to quite serious and possibly
even terminal catastrophes that's only a
speculation of course your speculations
are as good as anybody's what is not a
speculation is that the tendencies don't
have to be tolerated that's a choice you
can make it and not make it it's not a
necessity
the ability to make that choice is
roughly measured by your share in
privilege more access to privilege you
have more of a choice you can make it's
also measured by the freedom of the
society that means that for people like
us the options are wide open and one
thing we can be reasonably confident of
I think is that neither conscience nor
history is going to look favorably upon
an unwillingness to face those decisions
with care and dedication
[Applause]
very nice are there any mics
not in house okay if people want to say
something maybe stand up so maximize the
chance somebody will hear you good
okay you guys
we're here in Massachusetts John Silber
someone from I believe demand for our
source is leading the war against public
education and
he and his college using a variety of
text tactics there's a lady bill before
the Massachusetts
Congress which will take away collective
bargaining rights for teachers
completely got the union's
when is that some of us the teachers
unions are going to confront silver and
from that mistaken he was Simon
Kissinger
commission that investigated
purported to investigate
American policy in Latin America
one of his favorite characters
about him you know you make your own
decisions
yeah I mean the quarry the question or
the comment really is that John Silber
who's a chancellor something of the
state system or something is leading a
campaign now to try to undermine the
teachers union which is part of a
general attack on the public education
system sorry I then come some questions
about our personal relations which yeah
but to the side the because this is a
general issue that this is a there's I
think very little a serious issue very
serious one of the areas of government
meaning public participation that still
exists is the schools and at the left
end of the spectrum people like David
Rockefeller would very much like to get
rid of this government intervention in
the economy or as contempt I'm told that
the latest edition of
Paul Samuelson's economics changes the
phrase to government interference in the
economy no tell me I'm right that would
then introduce an important doctrinal
assumption into the
description so we want to get rid of
government interference in the economy
like public schools which have all sorts
of bad features like they cultivate a
sense of solidarity or of care for other
people like if there's a public school
system that's an expression of the fact
that you care whether the kid down the
street gets an education and that's a
very bad thing because you're supposed
to be you know you get this message from
infancy on through the television set
and everything else that the only value
of a human life is to maximize with the
advertising industry called invented
once so they're supposed to invent once
for you and you're supposed to maximize
them and that's the only thing you're
supposed to care about not care about
anybody else you know not care about
control your life and work that's out of
the door but maximize your own
fabricated once and the public the
existence of the public school system is
inconsistent with that because it's
expression of solidarity and care for
others and compassion and all sorts of
ideals that are not supposed to exist in
the system that is being created the
ideological system that's being created
it's not only John Silber there's a
major assault across the boards on
public schools I got a inkling of this a
couple of years ago and Alain Bernard
who some of you know sent me a
brochure
from Lehman Brothers which was being set
out to their you know Prime investors or
you know people who put a lot of money
in and so on and it was about new
investment opportunities and this one
was about what they called IMO's
give me a second to figure out what that
means but the point is you know prison
systems being privatized the health
system such as there was is being given
the insurance companies with HMOs
there's still this residue the
educational system so the next target is
going to be IMO's educational management
organizations which will be privately
run publicly funded of course all this
stuff gets publicly funded in one way or
another but the profits are privatized
and that will achieve great gains for
example by hiring teachers who are
non-union
staff that's non-union doesn't have to
be paid decent wages doesn't require any
security attempts and so on and so forth
so it's very efficient by some measure
and also it'll be a way of breaking down
this lingering sense of solidarity and
mutual support that the public school
system provides just by its very
existence so I think you can expect a
lot of such attacks okay not just on
that but on every other residue of human
life that reflects any value other than
individual maximization of invented once
anything beyond that is fundamentally
unacceptable
its reflection in fact that a lot of
people are worried about these issues
never write to be
the only thing to do is to go beyond
being worried about them doing something
about them
[Applause]
turn your attention in the light of your
comments tonight to Latin America and
specifically to the country of Colombia
and what's going on there and the
purported rationale for the ratcheting
up of US military support the purported
rationale being the supposed war against
drugs and a neighboring country to Kola
Colombia which is the nation of Pano's
and I have a particular reason for
wanting to ask you about Peru which is
that there is an American woman who was
a student here at MIT whose name is
Laurie Berenson who's been in prison in
Peru for over three years now without a
trial and perhaps in the
your comments about Colombia and Peru
you might also have something to say
about her situation well there's really
two questions one is about Laurie
Berenson who was a student here a couple
of years ago and is now in a prison
prison in Peru without trial and
you know that's something we really
could do something about I mean pressure
by the US government meaning pressure
from the population on the US government
on Peru would
deal with that case no question about
that so that's a simple choice you can
do things about it or not choices open
the more general question about the
whole Andean region
Colombia Peru Bolivia has to do with
several things there is there has been a
Colombia which the point Jack point is
that the
the u.s. is now increasing its military
aid to Columbia actually Colombia's been
one of the leading recipients of US
military aid right through the 90s going
up under Clinton it's also the most
violent country in there in the
hemisphere there are
State Department reports would suggest
that about ten people a day are victims
of political violence has well over a
million internal refugees
most of the violence is attributed to
paramilitaries including by the State
Department paramilitaries are
essentially a front for the military and
landowners
other atrocities of the military
directly there are also guerrilla
atrocities but the large majority are
government paramilitary they're all
connected to in complicated not so
complicated ways to landownership
resource control
now in the last year's narco trafficking
and so on and the u.s. is fighting what
it calls a drug war including and
certainly biological warfare so new
fungicides are being introduced nobody
knows what effect they'll have they're
supposed to kill coca but something else
happens not our business
crop spraying
just government and power military
violence everyone knows that the
paramilitaries and the military are tied
up with the drug traffic just a couple
of months ago a Columbia Air Force plane
was picked up
one of the Air Force commanders full of
drugs this is this happening all through
the region incidentally the presidential
jet of the
president of Nicaragua was recently the
subject of a major scandal in Nicaragua
kept out of that press here because he's
our boy and it was found that it was via
the jet was being used for a drug
transport from you know Miami wherever
going through Nicaragua which has become
a major drug transit area ever since the
u.s. took it over in 1990 but Colombia
is a much bigger one the whole drug war
you can't really talk about the tactics
in my opinion because the whole thing is
conceived in a way which you know it's
it has a kind of a rationality from the
point of view of those who are executing
the war but it has no rationality from a
human point of view so from a human
point of view the drug problem is in the
United States in fact the u.s. is the
major maybe the major producer or one of
the major producers of the most of the
drug that's the substance is it's gold
that's most rapidly increasing namely
synthetics they're made right here even
the drugs that are made that are
produced in the Andes or product
produced with u.s. chemicals the money
mostly goes through US banks the drug
problem as it's called is largely a
manufactured problem
so you want to figure out what it's like
the peak of marijuana there has never
take say marijuana there has never been
any medic medical evidence presented
that it's probably not good for you you
know just like good for you or something
I'm sure it's not good for you but the
evidence about it is extremely slim
certainly no medical evidence was
presented to justify its being criminal
in fact the American Medical Association
never favored the criminalization was a
different thing as an interesting
history the peak use forgetting the
criminalization the peak use of
marijuana is every I'm remembering
figures so like they may not be exactly
right but something like this was around
1980 and the criminalization level was
very low the reason was quite
straightforward it was people like you
you know and they don't get sent to jail
or their parents make a fuss and do
things about it and so on so those guys
don't go to jail
through the 1980s two things were
happening use of substances over a very
broad range was declining among educated
people and that's very broad marijuana
hard drugs coffee tobacco red meat you
know big spectrum of stuff it was
declining I mean all sorts of changes in
lifestyle but it was remaining steady or
maybe even increasing among poor people
which means and there's a close the
United States is
almost alone in the industrial world in
that though it has statistics on
everything it does not have statistics
on class that's an ideological decision
so you can't get figures on class out of
the Census Bureau you have to
reconstruct them in some fashion well
unlike other countries but there is a
closed class race correlation and among
the poor and hence heavily among
minorities there was either steady or
increasing use of the substances well
you take a look at the trend lines and
ask yourself when the drug war was
called and it was approximately when
they crossed so you could predict
victory in the drug war among educated
people because the trend lines were
already going down so I'll continue
going down and you could also predict
what was pointed out by Senator Moynihan
my favorite character but he does happen
to be one of the few senators who paid
attention to social statistics
social scientists and he pointed out
that we are determining to declare a war
a criminal
an upper a rise in crime or you know
something like that among mine are
we're determining to declare a crime
wave among the minorities that's exactly
what we're doing by declaring the drug
war and I think it was done and I think
it was done for reasons of social policy
this is a superfluous population they
are the counterpart of the Columbian
disposables
disposable people and
you want a crime war among them for two
reasons for one thing because you can
get rid of them toss them into jail and
for another thing you can frighten
everybody else and that's important
crime in general is a you know in the
United States it's a kind of a political
construct the the crime in the United
States is not very different from other
industrial countries you know with the
single exception of killings with guns
which is special thing about the gun
laws and the gun culture but apart from
that it's kind of at the high end of
other industrial societies fear of crime
on the other hand is way beyond other
societies and it's manufactured it's
manufactured by politicians by its the
only one of the very few countries in
which politicians stand up and you know
debate about who's going to be tougher
on crime
elsewhere crime is considered a problem
you know it's like cancer or something
you try to deal with it but you don't
decide who's we tougher on it in the
United States you argue about who's
going to be tougher on it back around
1980 the United States was pretty much
like other industrial societies again
sort of at high end in incarceration
rates since then it was going way up by
the end of the Reagan years it was like
five to ten times as high still going up
mostly a reflection of the war on drugs
victim mostly victimless crimes
possession of some sort or another which
is given extraordinary sentences that's
one of the human rights violations for
which the United States is regularly
condemned by the human rights
organization the outrageous sentencing
for victimless crimes which is just
targeting poor and the spoke the
disposable people and frightening the
rest so instrument of social control you
go over to the Andes you know the places
where coke is being produced there you
find another story so Columbia for
example was once a wheat exporter why
isn't it a wheat exporter anymore well
the u.s. flooded it with
subsidized US agro exports it was called
food for peace back in the 50s and it
undermined the Colombian wheat industry
not exporting anymore same thing
happened elsewhere
Colombia is a coffee exporter but coffee
is not very good for small peasants for
a very simple reason the u.s. refused to
permit
arrangements among the producers to keep
prices stable now if prices you know
fluctuate all over the place doesn't
hurt agribusiness I mean they got enough
but you know they own another enough
other things and so on so they can make
out if coffee prices go down if you're a
small peasant you can't do that you
gotta feed your kids tomorrow you know
price goes down too low you're dead so
that drove people out of coffee
production out of wheat production out
of other production well where'd they go
well you know they were being taught a
lesson it's called structural adjustment
all throughout neoliberalism all
throughout this region the lesson is
stop producing things for a local
consumption like say food we can do that
cheaper with subsidized agribusiness you
be a rational peasant produced for
agro-export and produce what's going to
make the most money in a grow expert
that's a rational peasant that's
following the rules well they did you're
a rational peasant you produced coca you
know grows well makes a ton of money and
so on so one part of US policy is trying
to drive the population towards
producing drugs and the other part of US
policy is to murder them if they do it
that's the support for the military and
the counterinsurgency and so on and
those two policies are going on side by
side and they don't anything to do with
drugs in the United States they do that
stuff as much as you want the drug price
remains stable the quantity of drugs
remains stable and so on this is an
internal us problem having to do with
serious social problems inside US
society and furthermore it is well and
agreed by criminologists and other
specialists across the board that the
best way to deal with serious drug
problems is education but that's you
don't spend money on that because that
has no use as for social control or for
eliminating disposable people so I don't
think talking about the tactics of the
drug war makes a lot of sense you know
the whole thing is constructed in a way
which is totally insane except for rich
people like New York banks most of the
money flows through instantly what's
happening to the money it's an
interesting question of course it's
illegal so nobody tracks it actually you
could track it so the u.s. especially
with computers and so on a Federal
Reserve System is which is well
regulated requires notification of large
deposits last time I looked it was over
$10,000 so you know it's a lot of money
suddenly coming in they tell right away
and in fact there was a campaign an
effort by federal prosecutors back in
the early 80s to carry out
some you know entrapment exercise
against banks in southern Florida which
were suddenly piling up huge amount of
money for reasons that nobody doubted it
was called off however it was called
Operation greenback it was called off by
the Reagan administration's drug czar
George Bush that was called off so the
money's supposed to come into US banks
where's it go well take a look sometime
the this is a guess nobody's ever
studied it but the US Department of
Commerce does publish regularly I think
quarterly tons of details about
everything you can imagine and one of
them is foreign direct investment FDI
you take a look at the record I haven't
done this for a year or two but I was
doing it for a couple of years in the
mid 90s you take a look at the FDI for
Latin America first and for that for the
Hemisphere the Canada is separate
category that's like Europe no but take
the rest of the hemisphere - Canada look
at foreign direct investment it turns
out that regularly about 25% of it was
going to Bermuda
about 15% was going to the British
Islands about 10% to Panama so that's
roughly 50% of what's called foreign
direct investment and the this is the
period of the emerging markets you know
everybody's excited about the emerging
markets so about half of it was going to
these places well what was it for
certainly wasn't building steel mills
notable veal plants all right many of
them in Bermuda there is a kind of
benign interpretation it's just a way of
ripping off the public by you know
evading taxes so that just harms poor
people there's a less benign
interpretation which is possible and
might be discovered if anybody bother to
look at it but I'm able to find one
technical paper and the whole literature
that even looks at the topic some of you
may know if there's some economists in
the audience but I can't find one and no
friends can find one and it's not a
minor phenomenon it's 50% of US FDI and
the big emerging market no big numbers
well you know make your own guesses
anyhow the whole system is so corrupt
and rotten from the bottom that to talk
about tactical changes is just beside
the point the current policies exactly
as you say are to increase the
military and
biological warfare component of these
policies abroad and to continue the you
know the criminalization of the
disposable people at home those are the
current policies
Laurie Berenson is a very unfortunate
victim of this I should say the violence
in Colombia you want to take a look at
it it goes back very deep it goes back
to a socio-economic system in which a
tiny sector of the population has most
of the wealth in a pretty wealthy
country and a huge as extraordinarily
high poverty rates starvation and so on
that's where the violence is coming from
yeah
here's the World Bank
the World Bank published a report saying
they made all sorts of mistakes you know
they were over enthusiastic and their
commitment all these wonderful things
were happening in Indonesia and being a
little over enthusiastic they kind of
played down the corruption and so on
that's not quite the story but yeah kind
of interesting the fact is that the
World Bank and the IMF were praising
Indonesia to the skies
along with Thailand Malaysia South Korea
for their solid economic fundamentals
and the way they'd been following all
the rules and all the Magnificent things
they've been doing and to their dismay
the major publications appeared exactly
as the whole system was crashing
it's not the first time that's happened
incidentally but it was a pretty
dramatic case so they've been kind of
running backwards ever since and yes
they did say they'd made a lot of
mistakes that's mild they knew what was
going on and decided they liked it cost
rich people in Indonesia were profiting
and rich people abroad for poverty so
what's the fuss no crisis now there's a
crisis so they're yeah looking back and
so on and they want to sort of
reconstruct the situation and they don't
know how because it may be that
Indonesia will simply come apart there's
there two issues that you raised one is
the disintegration possible this
integration of Indonesia the other
specific case of East Timor the East
Timor cases
is difficult to figure out I mean
Indonesia let's take that one Indonesia
has agreed to grant what they call
autonomy
within the Indonesian you know
Federation or something beyond that
there's a policy split which may reflect
two different tracts of Indonesian
policy or it may be two sides of the
same cynical policy nobody knows in fact
I suspect that part the people making
the policy probably don't know they're
waiting to see how things turn out one
policy track would lead towards
independence the other policy track
leads towards increasing violence so
while Indonesia is talking about okay
you guys can be independent if you want
it's also at the same time organizing
paramilitaries
arming them they're carrying out
violence in fact they're killing people
driving people out by the thousands and
the places you know exploding the same
going back to the question is happening
in Colombia it's not an unusual pattern
move towards peace negotiations and at
the same time unleashing the
paramilitaries with the military right
in the background to tear the place
apart you know if there's going to be
negotiations of some kind you want to
make sure that your thugs have it under
control
that those two paths quite commonly go
side by side
the you find it elsewhere to the in this
case I think it's hard to say I mean it
could be two sides of the same policy it
could be conflicting policies it could
be just uncertainty but they don't know
what's going to happen I don't think
there's much point speculating about
this frankly as I said I doubt that the
Indonesian generals know they're waiting
to see what happens what is significant
here as always is that what we do about
it could make a difference a big
difference so one of the factors and
undoubtedly a major if not decisive
factor will be how the United States
response to all of this and that's the
one factor we can do something about so
there's no point in speculating about
the others you know
what we do about these as for Indonesia
breaking up it could happen there's a
strong independence movement in Aceh the
what they call Durand Jaya West Papua
was given to Indonesia over the
objections of its population that has an
independence movement there's an
independence movement in the Moluccas
it could go all sorts of ways don't
forget that whole wreath thing was
patched like most of the world that was
just patched together but you're being
imperialism you know they put it the
other for the air reasons not for the
reasons of the countries so if you sort
of randomly broke up the United States
and put them under different flags and
so on and so forth yeah you have plenty
of violence after a while
because these breakdowns don't I mean do
with what's happening on the ground you
know like for the Middle East probably
the only semi-rational structure that's
been around in the last couple of
thousand years was the Ottoman Empire
which allowed local autonomy to a large
extent within a rather loose and corrupt
and
imperial framework okay you know people
were free or under the Ottoman Empire
than they've been since they could go
from one place to another for example
but they had national treatment like
General Electric ones but
then that's probably right for most of
the world actually it's probably right
for Europe too I mean the borders in
Europe are simply the result of
hundreds of years of mutual massacre in
the most violent and barbaric corner of
the world which is exactly what your was
for hundreds of years the highest goal
of Europeans was to slaughter one
another
and the only reason that came to an end
in 1945 is because they all understood
that they had reached a level of
violence such that the next time they
tried that's the end for everybody
that's why you have political scientists
writing books on Democrat aren't wars
among democratic societies and so on
yeah they know they're smart enough to
know that they try once more what they
been doing for the last 500 years and
everybody's dead so right now they're
not fighting wars but the borders that
are left from these wars are pretty
irrational and in fact along with
European unification you're also finding
devolution so pressures towards regional
autonomy which probably makes a lot of
sense because the borders didn't make
any sense yes it's different in the
United States I mean here it was easy
just wiped out the indigenous population
and settle it with a fairly homogeneous
population okay no big problems but
Europe didn't develop that way and nor
did the rest of the world it was all
imposed on them by you know by competing
imperialism's the Dutch East Indies are
what the Dutch were able to hold on to
and what form it takes
you know I don't think anybody can to
prescribe bits for them to work out
somehow I'm not easy
I haven't said that I don't think there
is much free trade in fact the standard
a standard figure among international
economists is that maybe 15 percent of
world trade could be called free in some
sense
trade not free
everybody supposed to admire Adam Smith
but you're not supposed to read him
that's very crucial if you read Adam
Smith you discover that one bad thing
that you discover is that his argument
for the market was based on the
assumption that under conditions of
Liberty a market will lead to equality
which is obviously a desiderata so
therefore he argues markets are good it
doesn't need to be quality out you also
find out he was against division of
labor or other things you're not
supposed to know but one thing you're
not supposed to know is that free trade
is based on what he called
free circulation of Labor
well you know he wasn't thinking so much
about crossing borders in those days
because nobody was even thinking of
capital crossing word or much in those
days but the principle is there so
surely you don't have anything like free
trade unless you have free circulation
of Labor around the world otherwise you
know you just all have labor markets I
mean we're not supposed to think about
that along with a lot of other things
but yeah that's true should you have
free circulation of labor well you know
that raises all kind of questions
questions about how people want to
preserve their own communities let's see
but then of course those very same
questions show up with movement of
capital it's just you're not allowed to
raise them in the case of movement of
capital ok so they're hard questions no
I don't think they have trivial answers
but you can't seriously talk about free
trade unless you have free movement of
people that's one of the many reasons
why the talk about free trade is mostly
a fraud
it's an ideological weapon it's not a
descriptive set
and there are many reasons not just that
Kosovo is what's called a crisis unlike
say Angola
Kosovo and it's bad you know it's not a
true like they've been a lot of
atrocities in Kosovo current estimates
are that about 2000 people were killed
it's about one night bombing by Jonas
Savimbi the
the reason Kosovo is a crisis and
Angola which is way worse it's not a
crisis is because Kosovo threatens the
interests of rich and powerful people I
mean Europe is disturbed by conflicts
that are essentially within it you know
and they don't want them to spread for
one thing to be a big flow of refugees
and for another you know if that whole
reason starts to fall apart you could
end up with wars between Greece and
Turkey and maybe a world war Russia
might get involved so it matters in
Angola it's just a lot of those guys
killing each other who cares
besides it's not a nice one to talk
about since the main killer happens to
be the person who was
highly praised and lauded as a great
freedom fighter in the United States
back in the days of what was called
constructive engagement which was a nice
name for supporting South African
Marauders who were tearing the place to
shreds and killing you know over a
million people well one part of it was
our freedom fighter in Angola who's now
still tearing the place apart not that
the opposition is so great either that's
another story
anyhow it's it's a huge massacre that
doesn't harm Europeans at least as long
as the resources flow out and they are
flowing out so Savimbi's forces unit is
being supported by mostly Dimond flow
which is monopolized by a couple of
companies and they can trace the death
technically there's an embargo against
diamonds from Angola and all the
specialists in the field say that it not
hard to identify the diamonds that come
from there but the name of that company
De Beers yeah the De Beers company
claims they can't do it you know only
all the other experts can but they can't
so they are oh there's a free flow of
diamonds out of there and all sorts of
you know Belgium is really is like that
and that's supporting one side the other
side they got oil which is going right
to Western companies so who cares
it's meanwhile they're killing each
other or starving or whatever but not
bothering rich people so it's not a
crisis
you can read the journals from Penang
and Cairo the same way I did it takes a
lot of work no but it can be done and in
fact nowadays for those of you who do
use the internet I don't it's a lot
easier
but the real answer is nobody can do it
alone unless they aren't crazy
so because you have to be a fanatic on
the other hand if people do it in common
that's not that hard I mean you travel
through Midwest churches in the 1980s I
mean I've done it you know you come to a
church and you know Lawrence Kansas or
someplace they know more about they know
more about Central America than CIA did
way more you know
because there was a lot of people and
they cared about it you know and there
were people who went up and back and
they circulated information and they
were in contact with others and so on
yeah that way you can find out about
things and in fact sometimes remarkably
well I mentioned the multilateral
agreement on investments a few times if
you don't know that story you ought to
because it's a an amazing story about
how
this Oregon you know activist groups
around the world without any says to the
press because the press was keeping a
lid on it for years how much can an
individual scientists do like suppose
you're alone and Tahiti you know and you
decide to work on quantum physics how
much are you going to achieve
if you are in a lab at MIT where
everybody else is interested to and you
can talk to each other and you
interchange and you know somebody read
something and somebody else comes in and
gives the paper and so on and so forth
yeah you find that you all of a sudden
you know it's magnified quite a lot it's
not different in this case that's part
of the reason for the enormous efforts
that are made to separate people from
one another I mean that's why there's a
barrage literally from infancy to
separate people from one another and
it's conscious quite self-conscious you
know you read the literature of the
public relations industry they explain
it and in fact goes way back if people
get together they're dangerous you keep
them isolated from one another there
isn't a lot they can do I can be angry
about things
and that's really the answer
clearly our turnout tonight
suggests that these are issues of huge
importance to this community that your
voice Noam Chomsky is one we want and
need to hear we could go with questions
forever but we mustn't Thank You Noam
Thank You audience
you